[Music]
the Billboard Music charts are usually
dominated by people like you hear about
Taylor Swift Justin Bieber but this
Christmas season an unexpected group is
making a big impression by doing this oh
[Music]
and one can do that no no there are the
Dominican Sisters of Mary from Ann Arbor
Michigan and they are burning up
billboards classical and holiday charts
right now their new album is hey soon
joy of man's desiring Christmas with the
Dominican Sisters of Mary and joining us
in the studio are two of the group's
members sister Joseph Andrew buck
Donowitz and sister Peter Thomas boy
this is great we needed this we need to
do here no let's start with you sister
Joseph Andrew people are I know watching
saying why are you sister Josephine why
is it a man's name you pick Saint names
and you go to we do and I have a sister
who's also a sister so she her name is
sister Maria Teresa and Teresa is my
mother's name oh my goodness and Andrew
is my father's name so we've got it
covered okay now how did this album come
about how did this whole came about
because so many people asked us to put
out it at Christmas CD so it's our third
CD but everybody really wanted Christmas
one so we finally said okay well we'll
do it and sister Peter Thomas when did
you start singing I mean I grew up
singing you know while doing chores
around the house and but it's really
been it wasn't something I did in any
serious way so to get to do it all the
time in our life as sisters is it's part
of our prayer life and then this is just
bonus that we get to sing together
in a different setting okay gift so many
people watching this now Minh and
gellick the sounds are angelic the sound
itself the blend of the sound the blend
of the melody with the harmonies is so
beautiful is it when did you know that
you had this I mean you sing and pray
you pray and saying
together but when did you know you had
that magical a lot of musical talent and
we use it a great deal in the community
it's part of our prayer life and so it
just kind of flows out so everything
that we sing really is a prayer and so
the the sisters just break into
harmonies and we just have fun you just
loved what now when you want to really
just hang back and like you're not doing
the prayer life thing what are you
singing I mean like heavy metal Molly
Hatchet like what are you saying these
songs that are very upbeat pieces in
when you're Mother Superior mother
assumptive who's amazing she
there's a wonderful ap feature that just
came out about this recording and and
she said it's the music is a like about
beauty in general that the sound is
beautiful and when you hear beautiful
music it does something to your soul oh
it's true it's so freeing and it's so
uplifting and it's so peaceful it's like
how do we find peace in the world today
music is a beautiful outlet pope john
paul ii would say that the good the true
the beautiful are like a magnet in our
hearts and so i think we all have to
respond you you just can't not you have
to there's something about seeing music
live - i think a lot of people like to
see music live and it touches you in a
different way sister Peter Thomas what
do you pray for in a daily basis what's
your what's your big big go-to there's
so many intentions in our world today
you know but I think first we have to be
Saints that's we're each called to
respond to God's love and so the first
thing I pray for is God help me become
who you want me to be but then there's
so many intentions in the world so many
needs and every one of the people in the
world who has those needs as a place in
our prayers as a community sister Joseph
Andrew what do you pray for it's going
to say we really do represent the church
or we pray now we have individual
intentions and personal intentions but
I'm very much aware that I should be
imaging Mary in the world today and
especially at Christmas when she is
carrying Christ joy congratulations on
this album and thank you for being here
and thank you for your witness thanks
beautiful and I love the habit of non
sorry but that's my favorite